it's Greg here with Kat Alvarado I'm
about to film some videos for YouTube
with her but she I found out doesn't
watch many movies but she's seen some of
the Saw movies maybe all of them
actually she hasn't seen our new sketch
that we posted recently so I was like
well I got a show cat or sketch that if
she's seen some of the Saw movies this
sketch is called Greg saw ok oh my god
just get ready for it not sure it's your
brand of humor and by the way it's at
Alvarado I memorize all this we'll be in
New York performing comedy on November
56 what Eastvale comedy club and she
will be at the mockingbirds on november
7th at 8:30 november 8th at 8:00
how could mean these two boots Brooklyn
[Laughter]
November 9 at 8 p.m. in all of New
Jersey affair everything's a five-minute
drive in New Jersey yeah yeah gonna
introduce this sketch and so on I'm so
excited we worked so hard on it it gets
crazy I'm letting you know that okay it
starts off slow but it gets crazy for
you guys you don't know has been a scary
Halloween Horror Nights for the past two
years so for the past two months he's
been living here I'm putting scare
pranks on him to show who's boss
[Music]
every morning at 6:00 a.m. this guy
wakes up to take a piss
how do I know this because the damn fan
wakes me up every [ __ ] I don't know
what's gonna happen
[Music]
he's all tense like
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like you guys are a couple how's the
makeup sex
[Music]
now get salsa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know why most people don't
survive my traps where the rules are
always so sick a John I know this is you
John watching porn while ago stop trying
to talk
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
90 seconds
[Music]
dude it's 6:00 in the holy [ __ ] you
didn't do this no I didn't do this
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
oh wait that's a prank - it has to be it
there has to be
can't do that I'm using it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
over
[Music]
[Music]
there it is cat
there's our Halloween scare were a lot
of reaction make you laugh curse you out
all the same like two weeks two solid
weeks like every team doing YouTube and
Patriots up and then like alright it's
11 p.m. to start working on such a [ __ ]
story that remind me of just how much I
hated watching the Saw movies cuz it was
my boyfriend at the time who made me
watch them oh yeah so it was emotional
recreation well I'm glad you got to
watch it yeah glad you got watch my dick
get ripped off thanks for the burka yeah
hey apparently so cuz camera turning off
now